well yeah you can't you can't be a  phoenix unless you burn first right you  got to burn in the flames in order to  kind of emerge with a greater wisdom  right but I think the thing is Danica I  mean frankly I think it all sucks it's  terrible like there's nothing like sexy  or romantic about like trying to make a  change it's a very difficult  uncomfortable you know inelegant thing  and I you know to the extent that the  internet paints it as you know something  that's that's easy or that can be  accomplished you know without discomfort  I think is a disservice to people I  think it is important to tell people the  reason it's hard is because whatever  you're doing whether it's gambling or  you keep getting into the you know the  same bad relationship or you know you  drink too much or whatever you know the  changes that you're trying to make it's  important to understand that that  behavior exists for a reason